when is it time for an artist to get an
agent
that answer is going to be different
depending on whether you ask the artist
or the agent
um you know
popular media has done a great
disservice
to creative people in the expectation
they have created for what an
agent does because there's this whole
mythology that agents discover
unknown people and turn them into stars
and build their careers
and in my experience that is is is
it's like a unicorn maybe it happens i
don't know those people
i've never had that agent um
and when i tell people this they're like
well what do you pay them 10
for and oh my god they take 10
of the jobs you get yourself and i say
i say they
they bring the value because my agents
at least
negotiate my deals and typically they'll
if nothing else get what they call an
agent fee which means the client pays
the 10 percent
um sometimes they get me more money
sometimes they get me
more per diem sometimes they get me a
better hotel room
but even if they didn't do any of those
things there is a cachet and a prestige
to having an agent
and at a certain point in your career i
think you are expected to have an agent
um having said that i know some
really prominent people who don't have
agents you know
just like some of them don't have cars
and you know bill murray doesn't have an
agent he has an 800th number so
if you're bill murray you can do that um
but you know i i i just
the reality with an agent is i don't
think any agent
agents agents are it's again we have to
remind ourselves we think of ourselves
as artists we think that this is art and
we are creating art
it's a business everybody's in this for
business
you know except lunatics like like me
and um those agents make 10
and if you make diddly squat
10 of diddly squat is not going to
look good on their ledgers and so
they're not going to sign you
um they don't they're not in the
business of investing in people and you
you know you might say oh well that's
kind of harsh and you know why don't
they take a chance but
again remember there are all those
successful working people out there
remember we were talking about the
volunteering why would you work for free
it's like who's gonna pay you when there
are a hundred experienced people over
here
that they could also pay so why is an
agent gonna build your career
when there are all these experienced
people who don't have an agent
who are making a good salary you know if
they're going to invest i can invest in
those guys and they're still not going
to invest in those guys
so you know it's it's you really kind of
have to be in that position where where
your numbers are worth you know cashing
in on
and the other thing is typically um
agents will a when you're when you're at
that place an agent will will
seek you out you know you've you've won
a
festival award and and that could be an
exception too i mean maybe if you just
had this amazing festival film
maybe they would roll the dice on you
but that's probably in anticipation of
the fact that
you know netflix and hulu and amazon are
going to be offering you some
some opportunities um
but uh you know there are people you
know who feel you can get out there and
cold call agents
i i early on had an agent you know who
i just sought out but but
they didn't do much but take ten percent
and you really have to consider that um
uh you know why are they signing you and
and if
if they're just if you're just 10 to
them then then
and and they're not a brand name they're
not a recognizable agent i mean
is that the right thing and i i'm not
saying it is or it isn't because i don't
know i mean
you know maybe that little bit of
prestige is a thing that
you feel works maybe somebody who would
hire you also thinks
it works but you have to realize that
that the premium agents the people at
the big seven
they are who they are because of their
their rolodexes
you know they can pick up the phone and
call those people you want to know those
people you want to know
will take their calls they'll answer
their emails and
you know joe joe nobody they're
not going to take the calls and they're
not going to respond so
you know it's all it's all a matter of
influence and
i do feel like you know sometimes
there's projects i want to work on and
i'll tell my agent
you know and i'm saying you know make a
call to these people and you know let
them know i'm interested and
do you know anybody do you know this
person do you know that person
um you know but but by and large you
know my agent is not calling me up
with jobs every week it's very rare they
send me a job
and and they don't call me up with with
new clients
and i've talked to some peers and a few
people have slightly different
experiences
but by and large this is the average
this is what you know most below the
line agents are like
and i think most director's agents too
um
when you ask that question to the artist
the artist is going to say i want an
agent right now because they
have bought into that mythology you know
they think that
that i'm talented i'm good i have
something to show
and the only way i'm gonna break down
those doors
is if i get somebody to walk me in and i
need an agent
and and it's just it's just not true and
it's it's
it's not going to happen for a lot of
people and just like i said earlier
if if your thinking is rigid such that
next step is agent you don't get agent
you're stuck
you're lost you know you have to you
have to negotiate
past that roadblock um because you know
maybe you will get an agent you know
maybe you get an agent later i mean i've
had several agents
but um you know the thing is is that my
experience in this business is
even when you have an agent you still
have to do it all yourself it's
all on you everybody and again it's a
human thing because look
i would love for somebody to show up and
say oh brad you know here let me take
you and
get you this meeting and here's a job
and here's a limo
and we're going to take you to your new
house in beverly hills and
you know that's that's the dream isn't
it for every human being but
it's just not the reality i mean just
like
again there's the exception sure that
happens to some people you know but if
it doesn't happen for you does that mean
you're going to stop
you know i've been a very working class
filmmaker all my life and i've had
agents and i've been
a member of the canadian society of
cinematographers and i've been
a member of you know the international
uh cinematographers guild um
i've done a lot of things and i have a
lot of associations and a lot of friends
and you know sometimes you know noel
vega will call me up and
suggest me for a movie that leads to a
bunch of other stuff and that's great
and it happens
you know but i can't wait around for
that to happen i can't
i can't um
make achieving my goal dependent
on an external force or an agent you
know it's it's really
again like i said i have an agent i've
had an agent for quite a few years and i
like him i think he's a really good
agent
but you know i'm not waiting around for
him
you know i he does what he does and that
is
you know um that is just complementary
to what i do i
i run my own show i just recently had
for for california christmas shawn and i
hired a publicist
and we really liked our publicist and
it's something that i did because i had
wished i had done it earlier in my
career and i really didn't
um you know because you're on films and
you're with companies and they have
publicists
but eventually you come to realize that
those publicists are not publicizing you
they're publicizing the movie or the
stars
or the production company or the
director um you know but if you hire
your
own publicist that publicist is
publicizing you
so um you know but even with this
publicist on
i still had several days when when the
movie was blowing up on netflix
where i sat in front of my computer
posting and
answering and emailing literally all day
and i wouldn't stop to eat
and i would work through the night and
into the next day like a crazy person
and my you know kathy was like you know
you're good you're gonna
hurt your health you're insane and i
said you know kathy
this movie is not always gonna be at
number one and while it's at number one
i have to do this if i if i don't do
this
and people have forgotten it's going to
be too late
and people could say i'm a crazy person
and i didn't have balance
and maybe they're right you know i mean
how do we ever know
that we're doing the right thing but but
in that moment i felt that's what i
needed to do and
and so that's what i did um but you know
you asked about agents and i gave you a
life philosophy
but i like that
you